thank you for letting me hang out with
you and your family occasionally thank
you thank you you up my cool Factor yeah
quite an accomplishment or like who's
that tall guy yeah
who's that tall lady hanging around
they don't know you know they don't have
any like they don't want late night TV
they don't know any you know there's no
notion of that right right for them well
when we were growing up is like Johnny
Carson and sure yeah SNL and of course
you get to do the whole thing I uh if
it's okay I'll come over to the house
and um Blair you'll come with me and
we'll load up a bunch of like best of
Conan stuff on a computer
yeah I need your a bunch of their guns
we're going to
um all I need is about six hours with
your kids and some energy drinks and
then that'll be kind of a large screen
they love The Simpsons there you go but
I literally were like he wrote on The
Simpsons and they were like okay right
now we like now
he was an accountant on The Simpsons
I was gonna say because you said that
you're gonna take Blake to her house you
can just email YouTube clips and stuff
no I need to I need to be there and I
need to be gesturing to a screen going
see now wait wait for it wait for it and
then kapowi what do you think guys what
pay attention they're like 11 they'll be
like yeah all right
they start crying
all right load up the next one you're
bringing Blaze all right bring up the
next one he's the AV guy yes sir yes sir
here it comes
another remote of you delivering food
yeah Chinese food delivery here we go I
think a guy who delivers Chinese food
right you've seen them right hey
pay the attention mom who is the
guy who lived under the stairs who lived
under the oh that was Letterman that was
uh yeah see that's why I need to be
there to educate them right I don't want
them see if I let you do it
Letterman yeah if I let you do it you'll
you'll be like oh I showed them all the
classic Lettermen
and the kids will be like man that
Letterman's so sharp so good and I'll be
just you know okay yes he's the best but
I'm coming over I'm coming over play
play I'm there dude yeah we're gonna do
we're gonna put the money we're gonna
put we're gonna have it transferred to
like 16 millimeters and show it Anna all
right now coming up next you see this is
1998 Conan now you see my face fill out
a bit
uh anyway
um such a joy having you here thank you
so much congratulations on everything
and uh and especially cocaine bear and
give my best to your old man all right
you give my best to Eliza I call her my
old lady I call her your better half
so does everybody